e aí
e o que sabiam que moçambique até 2013
segundo o ministério da educação apenas
39 por cento das mulheres tenham acesso
ao ensino superior
bom e que desce a percentagem que perfaz
100% apenas vinte por cento delas segue
as regras técnicas
e em nosso país que culturalmente o
homem é o provedor da família as meninas
são ensinadas desde a tenra idade a
cuidar do lar e da família para os seus
pais não cabe o que a sua filha possa
subir uma antena de telecomunicações ou
mesmo arranjar um computador foi graças
a este tipo de pensamento que se criou
abaixa a fluência das meninas nas áreas
técnicas e um certo medo a seguir essas
mesmas áreas
eu estou aqui hoje para chamar atenção a
estabilidade que muita das vezes passa
despercebida estamos e caminhamos para
uma era onde a tecnologia a programação
faz e fará parte do nosso dia a dia a
título de exemplo levantamento do
dinheiro latam
o pagamento de contas usando o telemóvel
ou mesmo o whatsapp que nós usamos todos
os dias para que esses mesmos processos
que funcionem existe uma programação por
detrás delas se o mundo gira ou se rege
em torno de linguagem de programação
vocês não gostariam de saber de onde é
que vem a programação
é a primeira linha de código que foi
trazido ao mundo foi foi uma mulher sim
ada lovelace isto é 1833 e há quem diga
que programar é complicado demais para
as mulheres então é preciso que se
devolvesse a mulher porque programar
veio de uma de nós por essa razão fiz da
minha missão fazer com todas as meninas
desta geração tem a gosto pelas áreas
que atualmente as amedrontam começando
por fazer parte de algumas iniciativas
que incentivam e inclua as mulheres a
seguir essas áreas atualmente existem
várias vezes tem várias iniciativas no
mercado que tem objetivo principal
objetivo de plantar a semente ter aqui
no coração das meninas ainda cedo
criando uma certa curiosidade e gosto
pelas áreas tecnológicas
e vocês acham mesmo que programar é
assim tão complicado
e aí
e quem é que deixa eu mostrar uma outra
perspectiva quem é que faz o gosta de
fazer bolos
e como que normalmente vocês fazem doces
bolos
e vamos começar vamos pegar o título de
exemplo o bolo de laranja
ah tá fazendo um bolo de laranja vamos
fazer juntos nosso bolo que ingredientes
nós precisaríamos
[Música]
o fermento trigo certo para o nosso bolo
misturar íamos primeiro o açúcar
e os jogos o óleo
é misturarmos bem dia de adicionarmos o
trigo e o fermento
nós não estamos a forma e colocamos o
bolo para assar esse eu vos dissesse que
o que acabamos de fazer a programação é
fácil não é se paramos para pensar todas
as nossas atividades são algoritmos de
programação para atingir um certo
objetivo a única diferença é que para o
bolo nós teremos os ingredientes eo modo
de preparar e na programação os
ingredientes e seriam as variáveis e o
modo de preparar siri a sequência lógica
de instruções sabe faça não é
e não acharam fácil
e no bode nós teremos um bolo de laranja
e no software e não apenas a programação
tiramos o funcional
não é fácil
e a dia estava ver uma imagem de uma
imagem não numa das redes sociais que
tinha um homem um helicóptero a tirar
umas fotos e no outro lado da imagem
tinha um drone cu
oi e a legenda da foto ela seguinte em
10 anos um drone tirou emprego de um
piloto e um repórter se não nos
reinventarmos e acompanharmos a
transformação tecnológica faremos
plantas é
ah sim então um pouco tempo e com apenas
um terço da população ao mês conseguimos
alcançar tantos feitos imagine se os
outros dois terços mulheres unissem aos
homens na programação o que vocês acham
que nós poderíamos alcançar o seu limite
eu estou aqui para fazer um apelo e um
desafio a todas as mulheres vamos
continuar o legado da água programar é o
nosso dia a dia desde uma pequena
receita de bolo até a organização de um
casamento é tudo uma sequência lógica de
instruções tecnologia prazer mulher
e aí